300 calls are meetings with members
chiefs chiefs of staff staff directors
and legislative directors since
september 1st and our policy teams have
also had dozens of meetings directly
with members and their teams i would say
over the last
24 hours you know you've seen uh you
know obviously there's been a the the
pressure of a timeline uh which uh often
can make progress uh can crystallize for
people what's at stake uh what we're all
trying to do here which is to uh make a
life better for the american people
there have been discussions about what
the path forward looks like uh
productive constructive discussions and
as i said as we said last night in the
statement i put out we feel we've made
some progress those discussions have
continued today uh and they're
continuing as we speak it was that
statement that i was referring to is
there anything more you could
delineate about what that progress is
exactly
well i think we all know what we're
trying to work toward here right it's
not a state secret um there are a couple
of members of the senate who
want to be comfortable
with what the buildback better package
looks like there are a couple of members
of the progressive caucus several
members of the progressive caucus
however you define it who want to know
there's a path forward on the build back
better agenda
what we're working toward is unifying a
path to
get both of these packages done as a
part of that and we all knew this from
the beginning compromise is necessary
it's inevitable uh some have come down
some have come up uh in in the numbers
and what we're looking at here that's
what the basis of the discussion and
some of the basis of progress has been
one quick question on north korea
they've launched another missile their
second one this week white house
reaction to that and to kim jong-un's
offer to open up a direct line with
south korea again
um well
first let me say that
in our outreach as i think i'll start
here um we've made specific proposals
for discussion with the north koreans
but have not received a response to date
so in our outreach from the united
states and we remain prepared to discuss
the full range of issues um i believe in
terms of the recent um
uh
incidents your missile launches you
referred to we're of course aware of
these reports we're assessing the
specific nature of these launch events i
think we've put out statements from the
department of defense and others in
response to them uh in terms of
discussion potential discussions between
the north koreans and the south koreans
uh i obviously we've we've made our own
outreach of potential engagement i'd
have to talk to our team if we have a
more specific reaction
go ahead oh let me actually promise i go
to the wire so go ahead okay um
progressives say they want a senate vote
on the reconciliation before they vote
for the infrastructure package and since
that's not happening today what sort of
assurances can you offer progressives
i'm not sure i'm following your question
the progressives want you know
assurances that the reconciliation
package will pass um if they also take a
vote on the infrastructure package so
what assurances can the white house
offer that's exactly what we're working
through one we don't know what the vote
schedule is or isn't today we leave that
to speaker pelosi uh as i said yesterday
and i'll just reiterate now it's 2 50 in
the afternoon there's plenty of hours of
time left it is not a secret we know
exactly what we're trying to accomplish
here exactly as you've stated is
something i've stated many times from
this podium
there is a desire and an interest from
some members of the uh democratic caucus
to understand what the path forward
looks like on the build back better
agenda a proposal and agenda the
president has proposed
that's what they're looking for and
assurance that there's a path forward on
that they feel the keys to that is
ensuring that there are enough votes to
pass that in the senate with the support
of senator manchin and senator cinema
that's why the president has been so
focused on working with them and having
discussions with them about finding a
path forward if there was a deal you all
would know there was a deal
but that's exactly what we've been
working toward and working through over
the past several days go ahead kelly is
this a trust exercise today where the
president is going to try to get
progressives to trust that perhaps
something like a framework short of a
full vote should be acceptable the
president is not going there to litigate
the legislative
path forward he's going there to make
the case for how these two packages can
help the american people uh he'll of
course answer questions and i'm sure
that will be a part of the important
engagement he has while he's on the hill
and some republicans who were working
with the president earlier in the
process on the one trillion dollar
package mitt romney among them
says this is profoundly disappointing
and he believes house democrats have put
their party ahead of
the needs of the country how does the
president respond to that i think
maybe the the time and energy of some of
the republicans in the senate who
voted in a bipartisan fashion to move
the infrastructure bill forward should
talk to kevin mccarthy and some of the
republicans in the house who
are opposing a bill opposing a proposal
that many of them
had expressed support for in the past
because
they're either being pressured by
special interests uh or uh by their own
leadership whatever it may be so uh we'd
suggest uh he spent some time talking to
them go ahead jen um our reporting of
the final agreement could come in at
around 2 trillion is that somewhere the
white house is comfortable with is that
where you're trying to land this
look i think i'm not going to negotiate
from here obviously
we know and we've said from the
beginning that some will have to come up
some will have to come down
and if there was an agreement on what
the final looked like you would all know
that in your statement last night one of
the common goals you cited was clean
energy does that mean there's any kind
of agreement on how you're defining
clean energy because obviously
progressives see it one way but you know
senator manchin i said he wants to
include natural gas which they don't
agree with well when we say clean energy
when i said it in the statement what
we're referring to is really steps to
address the climate crisis there are a
number that are included in the
infrastructure bill there are also a
number that are included in the build
back better agenda uh including go ah go
ahead i'm saying sorry we're gonna pause
go ahead
no no no thank you pool
yes thank you pool um
and so what we were what i was referring
to there is in the infrastructure bill
it includes a number of key components
in our view that will help address the
climate crisis investing in electric
vehicles getting rid of lead pipes and
making sure there are charging stations
there are also key components in the
buildback better agenda all of those in
our view are efforts to move toward a
clean energy economy
secretary yellen said this week she
would support eliminating the debt limit
entirely would president biden also
support a solution that effectively
abolishes the debt limit our focus right
now over the next 17 days or so
is plus or minus is
getting a debt limit getting a debt
limit raised in the senate that's what
we're working toward there's plenty of
time after that to discuss what the path
forward looks like go ahead jackie
thanks jen
did the president wait too long to get
seriously involved in these discussions
i mean this is happening so late that
speaker pelosi is like using a
legislative trick to pretend that it's
still thursday on the hill to meet her
deadline
well jackie i would say anyone who's
ever been through a legislative fight
before or covered it on the hill knows
that the negotiations and the deal
making always happens at the end it
doesn't matter how the process works or
how many weeks there are it always
happens at the end we're clearly at the
late stages of the process here this is
exactly the moment where people put
their bottom lines down they put their
best ideas forward and there's heavy
negotiating and that's exactly what's
happening and that's why timelines can
help make progress and then there are 3
700 department of transportation
employees who are furloughed
right now because progressives have so
far
declined to support this bipartisan bill
that would renew their baseline funding
setting aside that there is discussion
going on for a short-term fix that's
possible aren't progressives squarely to
blame for the furlough that's happening
right now well to be clear i mean every
member of congress is a free citizen who
could vote to support this
infrastructure bill including
republicans they could come forward and
support it as 19 republicans in the
senate did not and said they have chosen
to be influenced by whether it's
pharmaceutical companies or other
special interests or just to be strong
armed by their leadership not to support
legislation that many including members
of the problem solvers caucus suggested
they may so it just requires a majority
to support legislation in congress and
we haven't seen any real courage from
the republican side in the house in the
messaging to progressives about the
value of this package is there any um no
discussion
conveying from the white house that
if this
this package is around two trillion
dollars that the value of it the
investment of it is actually higher
because of some of the math that can be
done is that kind of an argument that
the white house is making to try to sell
this to progressives
the
case that the white house is making is
that
compromise requires everybody giving
little that's the stage we're in
but no matter where we end if we can get
something done here we're going to have
a historic
piece of legislation past congress
that's going to have a huge impact on
the american people and that's one of
the reasons the president wanted to go
down there today and lay down and remind
people we get mired everybody does in
kind of the
mechanics of legislating hugely
important part but remind people of what
this is all about and this is all about
lowering costs for people this is all
about addressing the climate crisis this
is all about helping women and families
get back in the workforce and that's the
case he'll make when he goes to the
caucus
if the president can't get this across
today after his visit to the hill
what message does that send about the
democrats ability to deliver and what
kind of impact might that have in the
midterms
well i think what's happening right now
is there's healthy debate discussion and
disagreement about the specifics of the
path forward and that's not a sign of
dysfunction that's a sign of democrats
primarily at this point that we welcome
republican support in the house
trying to work together to get things
done for the american people that's how
legislating happens so he's going up
there because this is his agenda this is
what he has proposed he feels
passionately about getting both of these
pieces of legislation done and he wants
to speak directly to the caucus about
that and he feels it's exactly the right
time to do that he also feels that
disagreement debate litigating
components of numbers or how much is
going to get a little more than the
other that's democracy and that's a
healthy part of the process too go ahead
yeah um you said at the top that the
president next week will make his case
for the buildback better agenda and the
bipartisan infrastructure bill is that a
concession that it is not going to get
done this weekend no
it's a conveying that the president's
going to have to continue to go out
there and make the case to the public
about what is in these packages no
matter when it passes um soon possibly
as soon as this weekend the united
states is going to hit 700 000 deaths
from covet
when when the u.s hit 500 000 the
president paused and essentially held a
memorial how does he intend to mark this
next terrible milestone and and also
what responsibility does he feel for for
the last 200 000 deaths well look i
think as the president said many times
he feels incredible responsibility for
everything that's happening in the
country including our ongoing fight and
battle
with kovid 19.
that's why he is focused on this as his
number one priority since the first day
he came into office i don't note that
we've saved according to outside experts
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
of lives because of the actions his
administration took including at this
point i think we're at 77 or 78 percent
of the public having received at least
one vaccine uh obviously
we'll all take a moment to pause uh when
we hit seven hundred thousand that is a
striking horrifying number of lives lost
uh to a pandemic people who lost loved
ones parents grandparents children in
many cases in terms of what the
president will specifically do uh we'll
have i'll have to get back to you on
when we have more on that go ahead
back to the president's trip to the hill
he said he's going to make its case for
his agenda but is it also his way of
saying enough is enough this is time to
come together now
well certainly he's going to make the
case for why
it's important that everybody come
together and move forward on both pieces
of these legislation so we can deliver
for the american people
i don't think the president is going to
say enough is enough that's not really
his vernacular but he feels it's
important now to go directly go to the
hill go to the democratic caucus and
make his case directly answer questions
and certainly talk about how we can work
together to make the lives of the
american people better
by kelly's question there does seem to
be a lack of trust like you said
progressives are looking for assurances
that there's a path forward that the
negotiators are going to continue on the
reconciliation bill
how do you govern if there's a lack of
trust among democrats
i don't know that i wouldn't put in
those terminology as a lack of trust i
will leave that to members of congress
to describe how they feel about each
other there's a diversity of views and
opinions within the democratic caucus we
know that we welcome that that's a
healthy part of having a party a healthy
part of
having a democracy what we know is that
the president has worked with members of
this caucus to get the american rescue
plan done
to move his agenda forward to this point
and that when we're talking about this
stage in the process a pivotal stage in
the process where we're litigating
details where we're having debates about
key components of two people it's
healthy to have discussions it's healthy
to push it's healthy to be out there
advocating for your point of view and i
think there's a misunderstanding of how
democracy and uh and uh and policy
making works when you suggest otherwise
not you but anyone following up against
on the climate change stuff
is the president's goal still to end
fossil fuel subsidies
that's his goal yes
go ahead jen um the president spent most
of his week doing his uh negotiating
behind the scenes here at the white
house in meetings on the phone
today he's making a very public trip uh
to the halls of congress so why the
change in tactics is this a
make-or-break moment
this is a moment where he feels it's
exactly the right time to go to the
caucus and make the case for why it's
important to work together to get this
agenda done
he wants to go back to the substance and
talk about how the components of each of
these packages will make a difference in
people's lives and he wants to have an
engagement and a back and forth in
person which as you can all note he's
had a lot of people here come to the
white house he loves that in-person
engagement and it's an opportunity to do
exactly that when there will be a vote
when there will be a deal
there's a lot of work going on behind
the scenes
about that this is just his own effort
to make his case directly to the caucus
is he trying to send a message by
literally meeting members physically
where they are and what message would
that be
that's my question
i think
okay
i i think i wasn't sure what you were
asking i i think he's look he was in the
senate for 36 years you know he is
making uh clear that if they partner
together if we work together we can get
this done for the american people and uh
going to their caucus meeting something
by the way he did in the senate it's not
it's not unheard of it's something
presidents have done in the past
is a way for him to go and make the case
for his agenda as i said earlier this is
his these are his proposals this is
something he passionately believes in
both pieces of legislation and so it's
absolutely right for him to go to where
they are and make the case for both and
one last one
during most of the day yesterday it was
quite clear that the votes were not
there for this infrastructure bill to
pass and yet we saw white house
officials and the president working
throughout the day to try and cobble
together the votes to pass that
legislation last night only to see the
inevitable happen with the speaker
delaying that vote so what in the
president's view did that work yesterday
accomplish and was it worth it to try
and push for that bill to be passed uh
on that arbitrary timeline well if the
speaker were standing here i wish she
was she's invited anytime she would tell
you it wasn't inevitable and that when
you legislate and when you are working
with a small margin which she is
in uh in congress to get something done
that timelines
self-imposed deadlines sometimes can
help crystallize for people and help you
make progress and we think it did
exactly that as we said in a statement
last night we're not quite there yet
we're still working toward it that
remains the case today
good yeah jim thanks uh what more can
you tell us about these trips next week
that the president is making can you
tell us what states or locations they
are how is this a multi-day trip or just
one day i think you said middle of the
week yeah and the fact that the
president is going on the road so to
speak is this a sign that he has
struggled to sell this plan so far to
the public for you
to do this at this point
well i i don't have the details yet i
understand why you're asking but i
wasn't trying to be secretive about them
we're still trying to finalize all the
specifics we may have more by the end of
today or first thing tomorrow morning as
soon as we do we'll make them available
it's going to be at least one day maybe
two days of travel next week if we can
finalize all of the details um look we
know that the components of these
packages are quite popular and i went
through this the other day with the
american people if you look at
the child tax credit if you look at
universal pre-k if you look at elder
care and ensuring that elder care is
something that can be cost effective and
achievable uh being able to cover it for
people
and also making sure our roads and our
rails and our bridges are rebuilt also
very popular as is addressing the
climate crisis but he also recognizes
that he needs to be out there conveying
to the american public why this matters
to them even if they like different
components of the package so this is
something he's committed to doing you'll
see him doing over the coming weeks and
months we made an assessment because
there's almost nothing more valuable
than the time of the president of the
united states that in this week when we
were in a key period of negotiating and
having discussions with legislators
specifically a couple of members of the
senate that his time would be best spent
here in washington being available
meeting with people and having phone
calls but uh we'll see he'll do that
next week too but uh he'll also be on
the road will these trips be in what we
think of as swing states or maybe even
the states of some of the senators who
haven't gotten on board yet say maybe
arizona
he's going to be i i understand your
line of questioning will get your advice
right what does it rhyme with um i
understand your question look he's not
going out to the country to do anything
more than communicate with the public
about how democrats are working together
to make their lives better and i expect
we'll have more details on the next 24
hours about where go ahead karen thanks
jen you've said a couple times that
timelines help make progress and that
self-imposed deadlines also make
progress in all of the meetings this
week between white house staff and the
president with lawmakers was the white
house explicitly telling progressives to
hold their ground on
not having the vote or not voting for
the biff until the second part and was
the white house also saying to the
moderates keep pushing for a timeline in
order to get to that point that we got
to yesterday so we're renegotiating
against ourselves
you know what were you actually telling
both you know continuing on these paths
yeah no character can actually bring
progress it's a good question i know
there's been some reporting out there i
can assure you there is no moment in
time where any senior member of this
white house was arguing for anyone to
vote against a piece of the president's
agenda what is also true is that we have
been in communicating with such a broad
range of members from across the caucus
that often we know where different parts
of the caucus stand and so we have been
in many ways liaisons along with
leadership to convey
this is where this group stands this is
where that group may stand and conveying
so that we can help reach a unifying
point and get across the finish line and
the vast majority of that without all
the specifics is very much known
publicly right there's a group who've
been out on television and out very
publicly and your colleagues on the hill
ask some good questions who have
conveyed we absolutely need to have a
clear path forward on the build back
better agenda in order to support the
infrastructure bill
they're also a group that has conveyed
that they want the infrastructure vote
otherwise they're not going to support
the reconciliation package so what we're
trying to do is uh gather all the views
gather all the voices figure out what
everyone's for and try to get both
pieces of legislation passed follow up
on my colleague mary alice's question
like you're getting all that together
figuring out where everybody stands and
they're making it very public but is
there a point where the president says
we know where everybody stands but now
everybody has to just put aside some of
those red lines and get behind his
agenda to get something done well i
think i understand your question but
look i mean and he's going to make the
case for the importance of getting his
agenda done today right these proposals
when he goes to the caucus but
ultimately it's a separate branch of
government right individual members have
a vote that's how the united states of
america was set up and i think you've
met a lot of these people they're not
looking to be told what to do or have
their arms twisted they want to be a
part of the discussion a part of the
engagement the good news is if you've
hurt and you've seen many of these
members from all sides of this debate
out there saying we're making progress
we're getting there we're getting closer
to an agreement we agree with that and
so we're going to continue to follow
this path
good i just want to follow up on that
question about the white house
email being perceived as
talking on both sides of its mouth
lack of a better way of saying it um
this morning ron claimed retweeted a
message um that was supportive of house
progressives who delayed last night's
vote on the beth saying that
um that that they were putting the biden
agenda on track and i'm just wondering
if you could kind of clarify
ron clinton's sort of seeming support
for that track of ideas versus what
you've been saying all week which is
that we were trying to get this done
retweeted to send a secret message to
the country that we were litigating
against ourselves and arguing against
our agenda
sit down with us
all kidding aside annie i know there's
been questions about this which i was
sort of touching on before
look um
we believe in um the build back better
agenda something that i think everybody
would argue the many members of the
progressive caucus are most excited
about right about any component of the
agenda i think the that ron claim the
chief of staff who i think most people
know who he is was just
echoing the fact that there are a lot of
good components of that agenda and we
should get it done
sometimes a retweet is is nothing more
than that saying that saying the
agenda's good um we also know um that as
i've as i said earlier uh that uh there
are there are there's a need to work
with members in the senate to get them
to a place where uh they have a
commitment to a clear path forward on
this agenda so no at no point have we
been arguing against or whipping against
our own agenda that would be terrible
legislative and strategic strategy i
think everyone can agree but we do feel
strongly and the president feels very
strongly about getting both pieces of
these legislation done and so he is
working for all the people who are
excited more about one than the other to
get them all excited about both pieces
and supporting both pieces
go ahead
thank you
senators mansion and cinema have been
wearing out a path between here and
capitol hill in the past few days
yesterday at least senator manchin
was forthright with reporters and saying
that his top line is one and a half
trillion dollars which may have some
impact on the breadth and length of the
and or length of the reconciliation bill
does the president have any idea what
senator cinema wants out of this
we'll let senator cinema speak for
herself
we'll let senator speak for what she
wants go ahead thanks
um
you just said no matter where we end if
we can get something done here we're
going to have a historic piece of
legislation uh are you slightly moving
the goal poster and maybe cushioning for
the result being something that
previously would have been thought as a
disappointment but now it's just
historic anyway
well first of all i think um we know
that there's going as i've said many
times that compromise means that some
people are going to come down some
people are going to come up that's a
part of what happens here but what we're
talking about is
a large package that will have a
historic impact on the american people
there's never been a proposal like this
that's come even this close uh to
passing uh that will help lower the cost
of child care of elder care of universal
pre-k that has done what this package is
proposing to do for the climate crisis
so yes there are of course parameters
for what we would or wouldn't be for but
ultimately uh what they're negotiating
around and what members are negotiating
around in good faith would be a historic
uh have a historic impact on our economy
a historic impact on people across the
country i can do a couple more here and
then i got to gotta go
yeah
um the uh the lifting of the travel ban
was gonna be for early november yeah
that's coming up is there a date
uh it's still on track to to meet early
november
november that's right and it will be
done by then go ahead um you mentioned
that everyone is probably going to have
to give a little on this um hence a
compromise yes uh does the president
have any specific policy redlines on the
reconciliation bill that you could
kind of lay out i know you've done that
before on previous legislation um
he understands that he may not get
absolutely everything he wants in this
package and others may not get
absolutely everything they want in this
package but i'm not going to outline it
further from here i know we've done that
in the in the past but at this moment in
the discussions i'm not going to do that
from here of the policy you can say
he's not letting anyone touch this it's
all important to him but i'm not going
to outline further detail from here at
this point in the discussions
but the new york times ran a great story
that a number of republican senators are
breaking with mcconnell to sign onto the
infrastructure bill if that's so are
there several cases with republican
house reps too and is that one way that
is
closely counting on their votes to
offset progressives
so 19 senators did vote for the
infrastructure bill and did support a
bipartisan infrastructure path forward
there have been republicans in the house
who have expressed support for interest
in uh some components of this
infrastructure bill in the past two but
kevin mccarthy has been whipping against
it it's a good question for him as to
why and why these members oppose it but
i think speaker pelosi isn't betting on
kevin mccarthy's caucus at this point in
time
i spoke with a few
organizations that are helping um
migrants from haiti and a couple of
concerns that they had um getting in
complaints accusations of human rights
violations or at the border including
people being refused medical attention
another issue that was um coming in was
that there were many people um deported
um that didn't have proper documentation
that were non-haitians that were sent to
haiti and so they're kind of dealing
with that on the ground have you heard
have you all heard any of those
complaints or information on the latter
i have i have not heard a single
incident of that i'm happy to check on
that case i will just reiterate that
as we've been implementing title 42 as
it relates to any
migrants who have been coming across the
border no matter what country they're
coming from her coming through in a
regular process
but in order to go back to a country you
typically need to have come from that
country and there are there are
countries where some haitians were
living for a short period of time that
they may have not had the proper
documentation to go back to that country
so that may be i'm not sure if that is
what the issue is and certainly that did
happen in some cases um as it relates to
medical care that is something that we
surged and i think you're talking about
from a couple weeks ago in del rio
okay which there's there's no longer
people under the bridge in del rio but
from a couple of weeks ago we searched a
range of resources including food
medical care and assistance to make sure
that people were getting exactly what
they needed i'd also note that an
immediate medical issue is also an
exemption for title 42 and something
that we would work to take care of
immediately all right guys thank you so
much
more we'll we'll be here
thank you everyone
yes
oh yeah
my phone finally has
if you forget to change it
oh
excuse me
you